I seriously can't believe how much the
campus has changed in 11 years so I I'm
just super thrilled to be able to come
back and share when my journey has been
like in the decade or so since I was
sitting in you know one of these seats
you know I don't know about any of you
but you know ten years ago I feel like
Stanford actually was a really different
place for entrepreneurship you know my
freshman year was the first year that
Facebook was available to incoming
students and this kind of notion of like
the young entrepreneur like wasn't even
really a concept right and very quickly
in that period we went through all this
incredible transformation in the tech
industry you know we obviously saw you
know the rise of sort of the the hacker
in a hoodie
it's a trope we saw just listening
incredible kind of transformation of a
whole bunch of industries we also saw
the 2008
you know bubble kind of come in for for
tech and really I think coming out of
that we had a lot of really really
incredible mythologies about technology
you know I think the whole world was
looking at Silicon Valley and they saw
you know these paradigms these tropes
these stereotypes dare I say of what it
meant to be a successful entrepreneur
you know there was I think a prevailing
idea that you were a coder that you know
you had a ton of confidence that you you
walked around with this vision that
propelled you into the future and you
didn't care what anybody else had to say
or think about it and you know I think
now when you scan the headlines there's
a really different story about that kind
of entrepreneurship and I'm super
excited to be up here because I
personally feel really passionately that
we as stewards of a technology community
we need to create a much richer and more
diverse set of role models for
leadership and you know that's you know
not said lightly because frankly you
know following a pattern of success
following kind of like the the pathway
that others have
that's actually you know literally you
know the way that venture capitalists
make investments that's literally why a
lot of you reply showing up to hear from
someone like me to hear about the wisdom
and the knowledge or the people that
came before you
so it's scarier and it's harder to
invent a different template for success
right it's actually riskier and it it
puts more of yourself at stake to
actually go out there and try to lead in
a way that is different and I've had
that tension and conflict in a lot of my
key moments that that I've had leading
up to where I am today and I'm hoping to
share some of that with you overall but
I mean if I were to just describe you
know what my journey has been it's very
much been about learning to reinvent
myself but to actually kind of have
ownership over that it's been learning
how to believe in others who believed in
me and then lastly I think it's about
learning how to kind of tie my own
success to creating success for others
and that's really like been the three
chapters of my journey to get to
speaking in front of you today so if
that's what we're gonna cover I do want
to at least do like a little bit of an
introduction so you know if 11 years ago
I was I was sitting here at Stanford
where was I to get to that point so I I
grew up all over the the US you probably
wouldn't guess where I'm from I'm from
Birmingham Alabama deep south I was one
of two non-white people in my high
school in a deeply segregated community
I think growing up there taught me a ton
about you know respecting kind of
differences in the world and and the
different points of view and by the way
in Alabama nobody went to work in
technology and nobody you know certainly
went west to California to go to school
so when I found my way out here it was
so interesting it was the most diverse
community I have ever been in and I
think when I when I came to Stanford
there was just like so much kind of
coming together in terms of ideas
different people to for coming from
different places I ultimately found a
home in the
I'm program here and oh my gosh design
was so much you know it just I felt like
I was using all parts of my brain it was
like you know you were you were
combining technology and engineering
with business and then also psychology
and art and for me that was just like a
huge kind of transformation for me which
I can talk about later and then you know
ultimately graduating from Stanford I
thought I was for sure gonna go down
this kind of design path but kind of
took me by surprise
ended up in technology and spent my
first few years out of college at Google
during a big growth period for them
doing a lot of different things I was a
speechwriter for Marissa Mayer and then
went and spent a lot of time doing
growth for the the chrome browser and
quick Google much to the chagrin of my
parents spent a few years wandering in
the wilderness to eventually found lever
and so maybe that's where all begin the
story how many of you all think that
you'll start a company someday yeah wow
that's a lot um you know about half the
room you're so much further than I was
what actually ended up starting the
company so a lot of people ask me how
did I found lever you know really
founding a company is for me at least it
was something that caught me by surprise
and I think that probably the first
thing that I would impart to you is like
how you make choices in your life really
is such a defining characteristic of
your leadership so for better for worse
every time I face like a juncture in my
life I look down one path and you can
see it really clearly you can see it all
mapped out you know exactly how it's
gonna go
and then there's this other path and it
makes no sense and you can't see
anything about it I always choose the
second path
and so I I had been pretty comfortable
at Google I'd been growing a lot of my
role I'd gotten to work with some
incredible people and then I chose to
leave and I think I chose to leave
because I didn't know what would happen
and I knew that
at that point in my life having been on
this straight and narrow path of
Stanford and then Google I wanted to put
myself in a position where I'd have to
take real agency over my choices and
over my life and you know I don't know
if any of you have had that chance to
really be put in a position where the
only thing nudging you forward is gonna
be you taking that step and you kind of
making a concrete decision and so I cut
myself off from all the paths and in
doing that really discovered a lot about
myself and I think that probably the
number one skill that I discovered about
myself was how to design myself and how
to redesign myself and that has been a
skill that I use constantly because as
CEO at lever I have to reinvent myself
and my job every six months and so what
it was like in that period was really
trying to understand like what I valued
what I saw in the world like what
resonated and I think more than anything
the people that I gravitated to and the
values we might share together so you
know at that time I was working with a
lot of different entrepreneurs in
Silicon Valley on a lot of different
problems just putting myself in
situations or I had to see how I'd react
and see kind of what what I would end up
gravitating to and I ended up falling in
with some old old friends of mine some
folks I knew from Stanford and Google
and we had kept in touch through the
same Burning Man camp who would
eventually become my co-founders at
lover and you know there's all these
mythology is right that exists about how
companies get founded and and I'll be
super honest like none of those myths
applied to us when we kind of found
ourselves together we were really just
three people we didn't know anything
about what we wanted to do we didn't
know anything about some big vision that
we had
for the world but we did know that we
were really attracted to a change that
was happening in the world and really
for us at that time the change that was
happening in the world was inside of
every organization we saw this really
big shift where you used to kind of work
at a job to get paid and then suddenly
people were working jobs to make a
difference and they were working jobs to
have impact they were working jobs to
grow you know I basically would have you
know conversations with all my friends
and more often than not we would talk
about whether we were fulfilled in our
work and you know that's a huge change
from our parents generation the
generation before that and really I
think you know if i zoom out and talk
about it from a macro cultural
macroeconomic standpoint what what we
had stumbled upon was like you know
there was a literal generational shift
happening in the workforce Millennials
were entering the workforce with a
completely different set of cultural
values you also saw the nature of work
really changing as technology
transformed every single industry out
there you know the the types of work
that was happening out there airlines
were now software and logistics
companies you know like hotel chains
were now actually experienced companies
work was really changing and the people
doing the work was changing and you know
that's essentially the kernel of what
would become lever so for those of you
don't know lever is a company in the
hiring and recruitment space so we build
the software that other organizations
use to run an entire end-to-end talent
strategy of course if any of you have
ever looked for a job you might have
actually used lever we power a lot of
the job pages that are online so when
you apply to a job that's just the tip
of the iceberg of all the software that
we have behind the scenes to help
organization run the entire process that
it takes to bring talent into the
organization and I think what we decided
to think about that problem differently
was to recognize that this wasn't a
transaction
it wasn't like GC post a job and you you
hire somebody but there was actually
kind of the relationship that people
were having to organizations and and it
was getting more complex and it was
getting richer and nobody had really
entered that space to create what would
eventually be like a talent relationship
management solution and and you know
long story short we saw an opportunity
there so that's a little bit about lever
but you know really I think what I'm
telling you all this is to tell you you
know that's the glossy kind of like
story what it felt like at the time was
completely different we had no idea what
we wanted to do and you know what we
ended up doing and maybe this is the
design program at Stanford influencing
us was to go learn from other people
what it was all about so our first nine
months as a company we spent embedded
inside of hyper growth companies mostly
technology companies watching them as
they went through incredible amount of
scale so this is like literally you know
there's people doing their jobs like a
bunch of recruiters and hiring managers
and interviewers and we were like you
know over here kind of behind a plant
like you know watching them in their
natural environment so we were really
employing like kind of like user
research methods and sort of like almost
like anthropological style observation
to make sure that we weren't those
entrepreneurs that were just saying this
is what we think is happening in the
world and then like blindly following it
we chose instead to actually observe and
watch kind of the entire the entire
process of what it really took for an
organization to hire and study that
patiently for nine months in order for
us to even get an inkling on what we
wanted to do or how we're gonna disrupt
something how we're gonna be different
and in doing that I think we founded the
company on a premise of really
you know debunking this idea of like you
know the start-up founder that has this
like the idea descending you know from
the mountain and and really kind of
embracing the humility of being
innovative through listening and being
innovative through empathy and being
innovative through our ability to you
know believe in other people's ability
to see the future and I think that's why
for me like believing in other people is
a huge mechanism right where I have
entrepreneurial success you know I think
that a lot of our mythologies about
startup founders tell us that these are
people that you know are just
relentlessly in pursuit of some sort of
inner vision that that comes from inside
of them but I personally have really
embraced multiple times in my career the
idea of like drawing from others and
being more connected to others being the
strength of my superpower so to speak
and certainly when it comes to literally
innovation and literally coming up with
new ideas for you know founding a
company or building a new product we
found that you know embedding ourselves
inside of organizations and studying the
way that they hired was in fact a really
really profound way for us to to start
the company so we got our start and you
know roughly 2012 form the team in 2013
we sort of actually found our own
offices exited that research period
started building the company and you
know really I think those those early
days it's it's really fascinating so you
know I said that reinventing yourself is
like a huge part of what it takes to be
a successful entrepreneur I think that
early startup days really reveal why so
nowadays we say that I'm the founder and
CEO at lever but actually neither of
those things were really true at the
beginning when I first joined lever I
actually just joined as a team member I
was a designer that was my title I had
business cards we thought we were very
fancy because we had business cards
and you know as a designer I obviously
was a huge part of that you know process
of doing the user research and of that
process of creating kind of a sense for
what our product would be and what we
would build the company around but
actually my co-founder Nate was our CEO
and he and very much embodies kind of
the stereotype or the myth of what a
great startup CEO looks like he is a
engineer who is you know very like
dapper tall he's very tall
you know white guy very charming very
persuasive very confident he's actually
also really awesome like I do really
love my co-founder and you know we kind
of had like all the markings of a great
yo stereotypical engineer Google pm like
male CEO but I think what ended up kind
of happening in this period is is really
revealing and I think for me you know
what I would impart everybody is I hope
it it stands to show that leadership in
many ways is what you decide to do and
what choices you make rather than you
know kind of being being born into it so
you know we started kind of working
quite a bit on developing the product
and of course as a designer is literally
doing design at the time but then since
I knew our early users I also became
kind of like the first person to you
know once we got people on our actual
platform like make sure that we were
closing the feedback loop making sure
that we were hearing kind of like how is
it going where the the like the next
things that we could build partnering
with them since I knew our early
customers then I went and found more
customers so I quickly found myself
building out our very early go to market
engine and you know that this is around
the time that we're about six eight
people really hustling but we hadn't
really taken down any serious funding
yet so everything's just like racing to
get to the point where we've built
enough of a business that we could
actually raise some serious venture
capital and and become like a real
business so we were like all hands on
deck pounding super hard trying to build
this business and then you know my my
co-founder whose
no engineer Google Pia and penny
co-founders like super mired and all the
feature requests that we had to deliver
on for our customers so we had that
rhythm of like me running the business
him running the product we had the whole
team around us obviously and then when
it came to fundraise it was sort of
funny because my co-founder is a CEO but
he didn't know anything about a revenue
about our numbers about our customers
about any of the things that the
investors ultimately would care about so
we decided all right let's go after this
together and we fundraise together we
got several term sheets in a competitive
round from our series a but it was
really it was really fascinating because
that whole period you know I still had
my business cards that said designer and
you know people would be like super
confused like why is this designer in
the room and like why is this person
like here right now like trying to
trying to basically pitch us and even in
some cases you know when I would be on
email threads with Nate they would think
I was his EA when he would CC me so they
would just sort of like be like oh yeah
my calendar blah and it was just such an
interesting experience because you know
at the end of the day like Nate and I
knew what we were doing and we would be
driving all up and down 280 going from
San Francisco to San Hill Road and you
know he he like really gave me a lot of
sanity like really like partnered with
me and acknowledging that that was like
a super weird thing the why why wouldn't
a designer be welcome in the room why
wouldn't someone you know who wasn't the
CEO still be able to like legitimately
lead the business right but this really
all came to a head for us when when
really around that same time you know my
we we had all these we were lucky we
were able to actually successfully get
you know several offers from VCS we did
ultimately kind of pick one and we start
started to work with them and between
signing a term sheet and actually
getting the cash in your bank account
there's actually this period where the
lawyers are doing stuff so we were in
that period and it's a really hot
period because you're planning for the
future you now know that you're gonna be
scaling the business growing the
business so Nate and I were locked
basically up in this the one conference
room that our office had and planning
all these things to the business there's
a really great time and I had it in my
head that you know oh we were gonna hire
like a head of sales and I'd like hand
off you know all this business stuff and
then go back to being a designer but
then our third co-founder Randall who
had the segment at our company all hands
for a number of years called getting
real with Randall so you can imagine
what kind of co-founder he is he was
always sort of a guy who spoke like the
truth and he he had this wisdom about
him so Randall kind of comes into this
this conference room to to interrupt us
and he goes guys something wrong and I
think if we don't fix this you know the
company will probably fail and if the
company fails you might as well not take
the money like little Bob we should we
were just like Randall we're listening
tell us tell us what's wrong and he goes
the wrong person CEO and you know I
think what Randall was speaking to is
just this like this choice that we had
as a company as a founding team as a
culture frankly about whether we would
kind of continue in this model call it
like the Sheryl Sandberg to the Mark
Zuckerberg model or whether we would
just write you know like right this
situation and actually just sort of make
make this switch there's a lot of
companies where engineers and technical
founders are like the CEOs of businesses
but we were a b2b SAS software company
and for the most part you know building
the business is like kind of like the
the the job definition of being CEO and
it was really decisive on for us I think
as a company it was probably our first
diversity and inclusion moment it was
sort of the first time we had to really
ask ourselves you know what kind of you
know culture do we want to be what kind
of values do we want to have
and you know frankly Nate it took him
like 30 hours but he came in he's like I
think it's the right thing it's like the
way to go and for me it took me like ten
days which in seed stage startup time is
like infinity of kind of wandering
around in this like weird head space
because I had never saw myself being a
CEO being a founder being a leader all
of this had happened kind of
incrementally over time and I think
that's where I kind of come back to you
know this idea of believing in others
that believe in you you know I think for
the people that already know they want
to be founders of companies
entrepreneurs CEOs great
that is awesome but there's more people
out there who can be those leaders that
don't think of themselves that way today
and I was once one of them and I think
in that moment of like wandering through
this like metaphorical desert trying to
figure out this choice that I had to
make and what it meant and what I wanted
and what I was going to do you know I
kept like ultimately returning to the
people around me and how much I valued
them and their beliefs and the things
they had sacrificed things they had like
put on the line the you know the team
that had joined and like had signed up
to work on this like what wasn't that
much more than an idea with their
passion and their talents and their
skills and then also our customers like
all the people who live like rationally
should not have been buying our software
and relying on it to do all their
recruiting they had backed us and they
had they had thrown their weight behind
us because of how much they believed in
literally in us as people and I think a
lot of people asked me so what was going
through your head what made you decide
to say yes it wasn't because I saw
myself in that role it was because all
these people around me that I trusted
really profoundly saw me succeeding in
that role so ten days later you know I
shuffle into the office and I tell Nate
and Randall okay thought about it let's
do this here we go
and you know they thought obviously it
was a great idea their support as
co-founders really meant a lot to me and
then of course we had to tell the team
and that was a big milestone so we like
hemmed and hawed about it we tried to
figure it out and eventually like sort
of got everybody together and told
everybody and the team was just like oh
yeah that makes sense ok and like went
back to we're like ok but then we
actually were still in this period right
where we had signed the term sheet but
we hadn't gotten the cash so we had to
tell our investor it was Dana Stalder
he's a general partner matrix partners
they've been in the VC business for over
two decades a really fantastic person
really fantastic firm so we had to tell
Dana and you know actually that was like
that was we were like oh no this is like
material information we really have to
tell people this but does this is this
gonna like basically blow up the deal is
this gonna make him kind of question
like what else are you hiding from me or
you know what else you know do I not
know or have you have you not told me
and you know we had another moment we're
like okay maybe we should just wait and
not do this now it was again one of
those critical choices we're deciding
what kind of a company we were going to
be and whether this was the right thing
to do or whether you know that it was
just another one of those moments and
you know we ended up just saying like
it like we have to we have to be
you know this kind of founding team and
this is the decision that we have to
make so not knowing whether this would
completely blow up the entire company
and everything we'd worked for we
invited Dana over we sat him down in the
one conference room we had this whole
thing prepared and so we sat him down we
like all told this whole story though
and Sarah should be CEO and it was one
of those moments that I don't even
remember well I think I blacked out a
little bit because I was so stressed out
but like time just like stretches out
that sort of thing but you know what
what ultimately happened is you know
Danny kind of looks at me feel like he's
seeing me for the first time I just
/ and he goes girl power high five so
needless to say you know for us at least
it was the right choice it was the right
choice and it was the hard choice like
harder for me
I think stepping into that was really me
making a huge choice about choosing to
see myself in a way that I couldn't see
myself on my own and choosing to
redefine my idea of who I was and what I
could contribute in a way that I hadn't
before and I think that's the beauty of
entrepreneurship I think that's what
attracts talented smart driven people to
this painful nebulous like journey of
being an entrepreneur because it sucks
like just saying it in many ways that
totally sucks you you make sacrifices
you make sacrifices with your your your
time and your wellness and your sanity
and you know to some degree if you're
lucky to actually have you know levers
now 225 people we have two offices in
San Francisco and Toronto we have over
2,500 customers we've raised 73 million
in capital we are all in all like you
know really on a path to success and
I've definitely have to say like once
you have that I mean then you know
there's there is so much responsibility
that comes with that and there's there's
a lot of pressure and there's a lot of
sacrifice but why we choose to still be
entrepreneurs and why we choose to still
be on that journey is because there's
just no other way to put yourself in
these definitive moments where the
choices that you make are just so
clearly creating who you are and I think
that you know for me is again coming
back to kind of my maybe passion or the
thing that I really care about a lot
nowadays is I think there's more stories
to be told in entrepreneurship and I
think it's all too easy to tell the
story that the world wants to hear and
tell the story where you just like woke
up one day
you knew you were gonna be the effing
like CEO of this like game-changing
disruptor start-up and you know I
actually you know my experience the
experience of a lot of founders a lot of
CEOs that I know is just so much more
complex so much more human than that and
I think what you know I would hope for
all of you to take away from you know my
story
is really that you know at the end of
the day it doesn't it doesn't matter
nearly as much your ability to see
yourself in your destination and I think
what matters more is to put yourself in
a path where you have to take risks and
make choices and you know in many ways
like we're so fortunate to be really in
the heart of Silicon Valley where
there's so many people to learn from
where there's classes like this where
there's you know other people you can
look to as mentors but truly my
experience has very much taught me that
you know they're there there's nothing
that can replace your ability to put
yourself in situations where you're not
sure what you're gonna do and we are not
sure what's going to happen and where
you have people around you that you can
trust to help you see bigger and more
clearly and where you push yourself to
actually you know I don't know I guess
be something more than you thought you
wanted to be or to do something more
than you thought you wanted to do and I
think that to me that's what authentic
leadership is and to me I think if more
people not only made those choices but
shared the story of their choices we
would pave the way for a lot more people
to find their way to leadership and for
a lot more people to you know be role
models for the generation that will come
after us so I'm happy to take questions
let's talk about pretty much anything
but thank you both so much
don't all rush are do you think if you
would have followed the copy
nice-looking ballad on somewhere else
should I repeat the questions the
question was if we had you know maybe
gotten started or incubated outside of
Silicon Valley would we have had the
same question would we have formed the
same company with the same results you
know I I you know literally no I think
like the situation's you put yourself in
really influenced you and the the things
you choose to study and and the models
and templates that you're exposed to you
matter tremendously so absolutely not I
think if we had exposed ourselves to
different inputs we would have gotten a
lot further however as we've scaled as a
company we have very consciously brought
in influences from other types of
organizations other types of customers
we've tried to mix in a lot of our
influences so to speak to consciously
brought in who we're serving and the
impact that we can have in the solutions
that we imagine are possible we
obviously continue that design thinking
kind of methodology in the company today
to do all of our ongoing Rd and to some
degree even influencing other parts of
the business so we are really conscious
about diversifying the the models and
the customers and the problems that
we're exposed to so that we can keep
keep enriching and broadening the
solutions we can deliver great question
yeah the hardest part in building my
company let's see people I have a
feeling you're gonna hear that from a
lot of the entrepreneurs in the speaker
series but you know there's kind of this
idea about technology companies in
particular that you know it's kind of
all about these like systems and
structures and like these these kind of
sciency things but you know a lot of it
is about people and I think in
particular as a CEO you are you are the
storyteller of the business you're
trying to tell the story of your company
not just to your your perspective
customers but to all the people inside
the company you have to tell them what
you're doing in a way that's that's
simple enough that everybody can
actually see themselves in it and can
run as fast as possible in the same
direction simplicity is really a
superpower it's one I'm still refining
it's one I'm still working on so you
know I think the hardest part is being
able to be a leader to larger and larger
and larger sets of people who have
greater and greater kind of diversity
and what their jobs are what they care
about are the tensions between them and
to keep a company simple so that
everybody can actually run in the same
direction and that's definitely the
hardest part started the company with
the idea that you weren't inspired by
space you were talking about and so
decided to do something about it or the
new kind of - everyone want to start a
company and then look for the closest
space they were interested in yeah I
mean so the question is like did we were
we inspired by the space and made the
company were there other wait like how
did we like end up and the answer is
like yes you know like I think I tried
to convey this but maybe not vividly
enough it's confusing at the beginning
like you don't really know what you're
doing you're I think like the most
important thing you're doing is you're
exposing yourself to a lot of
interesting ideas and surrounding
yourself with the people that really
like draw out the kind of creativity and
like you know ingenuity in in each other
you know I think the most important
thing you do in the early early stages
is you find the people you want to work
with and in many ways like finding the
people that mesh with you it does
involve some degree like finding the
problems in common or passion for
problems in common we all for example
loved working on the future of work that
was something we were just naturally
passionate about it drew us together it
was something that was really obvious
like you know in a time when everybody
was building mobile apps
and like companies that ended in ly we
were like all about b2b software and
that was pretty rare and special and I
remember that being like a huge draw for
why my co-founders and I loved working
together but yeah in the very beginning
you don't really know what you're doing
but the most important thing is to find
the right people to go through that like
exploration phase together with yeah I
have two questions one is that HR is it
a highly competitive space in Ohio in
entrenched spaces like big players and
so I was curious like what do you think
maybe you guys successful and - it's
like do you think you would have been
successful if you had just like
bootstraps or do you think actually
getting funding was a because out the
way you care about getting customer
money but like you said to them do you
think getting funny actually get you in
ocean to certain customers as well so it
was a two-parter so the question was
with HR being a competitive space what
made us succeed and then the second
question is do I think venture capital
is necessary for our success so you know
jury's out we haven't succeeded yet
we're on this path though I mean I guess
I'll coffee out with that HR is an
interesting category I actually think
all categories there's some degree of
there's there's there's a there's
periods and waves of evolution I think
actually HR technology is going through
a wave that you know this happens every
15 20 years in every technology category
so timing is really huge for picking
when you focus on an area and whether or
not you know you you have a chance at
success so I think for us what helped us
break through in a category that's very
old like ever since there's been
software there has been software to do
our problem we're therefore in a
replacement market and so we're selling
something better a next-generation
version of something people already have
not inventing something out of the blue
so what helped us were these
macroeconomic factors I mentioned that
there's a new workforce that actually
there's been this
massive digital transformation of
everything we do so you used to believe
it or not like give a paper resume to an
employer to evaluate them you know
obviously we digitized that into
software and we digitized job ads into
you know like monster.com and indeed and
these these online platforms but there
was another kind of wave of digital
transformation where you know truly like
one-to-one relationships the the rise of
the relationship was definitely a
concept that was driving and fueling
like a completely different way for
organizations to actually proactively
reach out to people like send them email
send them linked in some send them text
messages in some cases to proactively
engage talent instead of just like
posting a job in getting applications so
for us there were these macroeconomic
factors that had changed about the world
that had triggered this category to go
through one of these transformations
that do happen every so often and then
whether or not venture capital was
critical to our sex success you know I
tell a lot of people there's a lot of
ways to scale a company and you know
that they're just really different and
certainly if you go for a VC backed
growth strategy I mean that's gonna
drive and determine a lot of your
priorities a lot of the decisions you
make down the road I've enjoyed working
with venture capital you know I can't
even fathom a day when you you would
like mortgage your house to be able to
pursue like an idea
I think venture capital gets a bad rep
sometimes because there's all these
stories about you know the fact that
they're capitalists it's in the name
people venture capitalists it's a clear
it's a clear relationship I think it's
all about being as selective with the
VCS that you partner with as the people
that you Co found your company with or
the people that you hire you know I
we have always like had the luxury of
choosing kind of like who we want to
work with and we've we've optimized for
choosing with people that feel like
people I want to work with for a decade
and I think that makes a huge difference
so I have felt that you know we have
liked being on that high-growth venture
backed path it's not without its
challenges you do feel a little bit like
you're on a treadmill but I think the
key to making that successful is
remembering that you know don't don't go
for the brand names or the sexiness or
whatever go
like evaluate those people just like you
would evaluate you know anybody that you
were gonna work with yeah
oh my gosh question was how does Design
Thinking help me in my career gosh I
could do a whole hour-long talk about
that so I can't help but be a designer
right it's like so much of how I
formulated my way of solving problems my
way of looking at the world my way of
interacting with others it's what I try
to bring to my CEO job to my to being a
founder you know I think in a way you
know I don't get to like literally
design the product anymore much to my
you know single tier but what I do do is
use basically the same skill set in
designing my company so instead of user
research I'm doing research but my
employees and my customers and we're
users and instead of the product being
the product the product is you know our
strategy the product is our culture the
product is the company right and so I
actually used the same skills I try to
use I I feel like a lot of design
thinking is about how you listen to
others and listen both to what people
say and what they don't say or what
they're trying to express identifying
needs both explicit needs and latent
needs and being able to actually
articulate needs not necessarily
solutions because as soon as you anchor
on a solution it's the whole difference
of I need a ladder versus I need to
reach something on a high shelf right so
I think being able to separate out needs
and solutions and then being able to
actually lead a lot of people in
generating lots of solutions different
solutions alternative solutions that
process is so huge because when you have
cash limits limitations bandwidth
constraints like when you don't have
that higher with the explicit skillset
you got to generate a lot of solutions
because basically you don't have any
ladders around and so being able to
think as creatively about our team and
our culture and like how we solve the
problems that we have with the people
and skills that we have that is very
much a design thinking exercise and I
think the other thing I take away from
design thinking is the importance of
storytelling I kind of mentioned this
earlier but you know in many ways giving
people the capability to see something
that doesn't yet exist such a huge part
of the value that I can drive in the
value I can give to the team and I do
think something I love about design
thinking any of you have the chance to
take design classes here at Stanford
should it changed my life no promises
for you but I would definitely say that
there's just this critical need to
inspire other people in that design
thinking discipline and that is just so
valuable to to entrepreneurs yeah how
would you say that what was it like
working at a kind of corporate
environment before going into a startup
you know I feel really lucky that when I
was in Google I had a lot of really
diverse experiences some of them were
very much being a part of a big kind of
like machine I was part of the team that
took Chrome to market and that was like
a big effort and we definitely had some
amazing people that whole initiative was
led by sundar and so I got to see just
like top-notch people at the top of
their game but my first ever job at
Google was a great lesson in
entrepreneurship because it was
essentially speechwriting former Smyre
she was VP of search and user experience
at the time and nobody had ever had this
job and they had no idea what it would
be and I had I had no idea why I was
doing it or why I had been selected to
do it and it was this great experience
for someone who had been at Stanford and
had just been on this like achievement
path for like such a long time to
suddenly be in a job that was entirely
subjective that you could not succeed at
no matter how hard you tried
and coping with ambiguity was probably
the most valuable thing that I got to
experience early in my career that I
think was hugely fundamental for my
success as an entrepreneur and you know
I think you can do that no matter what
environment you're in if you're in a
corporate environment just seek out
situations where there isn't a path
there everywhere like a lever we have
them everywhere and like people just
have to kind of pursue them so I think
it's more frame of mind and you know I
would definitely say why I went to
Google is just following great people so
if you follow great people no matter
what types of companies or environments
they are I think you will learn a lot